[Music]
[Music]
Queen Celine arrives at the met with a
fierce Vegas bevel to boot as she says
goodbye to Las Vegas Celine fabulous
Canadian Queen Matt gala realness you
drop of your fabulous describe your look
thank you so much I'm very proud to be
here this is Oscar de la Renta Fred
Leighton Noel Stewart cloaca slime for
the shoes and very honored to be here
what do you have to do with the design
do is this a collaboration did you from
from Aida see there were more than
generous these people are so exquisite
talented big hearts they were amazing
and they really wanted me to feel at my
best and they gave me the opportunity to
be part of everything I have my own
stylist but Fernando and everyone at the
house of Oscar de la Renta gave me the
opportunity to be part of everything
this looks like the kind of outfit that
means you're gonna party till 5:00 in
the morning with those legs it's maybe
six this is a shimmy dance full celine
like i need you to go back down and lay
Lady Gaga's styling well actually its
candidates two kind of looked at 24/7
you know what
you wake up in the morning go to bed
with it it works it's an homage to the
end of your Vegas time with the
headpiece everything that I feel that at
my best without something pretentious
it's the beginning of something it's not
an end but it's a beginning
congratulations you are so fierce
what does camp mean to you Camp is to be
at your best and it's so like luxurious
and feel fierce and be feeling like
there's no tomorrow
tonight is your night suspense alene we
love you we love you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]